simply stated there is no doubt the
Saddam Hussein now has weapons of mass
destruction they're dialing up the
rhetoric on Iraq let's see if we can
nail them down okay let's get to work
working on a theory of the
administration has already decided to go
to war and now focused on how to justify
it it's not a theory we're working on
something important that's why I'm here
to make you an offer
jogo Wow anything walks like he has a
Bronze Star what do you want to know
everything the administration doesn't
want us to know a secret war planning
room has been set up in the building
where I work and which building is that
the one with five sites how real is the
chatter about Iraq Barry are you looking
into an Iraqi connection always actually
come out said I think publicly maybe
it's just backroom speculation can't we
hit it harder than this I know that a
man named Ahmed Chalabi wants to replace
Adama saying that the neocons are
pushing for the invasion and you are
quickly becoming my favorite
roof is coming from every major media
outlet in the country except yours right
I'm speaking to you because I'm an
American citizen and I don't like what
these people are doing you guys see this
what we do when the government says
something you only have one question to
ask is it true search is underway to
find those responsible we write for
people whose kids get sent to war
our readers need to know presidents can
invade Iraq we're gonna run or whether
he comments at night
there's a SAP
there's always something you don't see
coming
I don't care about the truth they want a
war they're gonna get one
I said all due respect sir my sources
not even be in this room did you
actually have sources in the room no it
was fun watching them sweat like [ __ ]
in church
you